quelques semaines après la sortie du
biopic événement sur grégory lemarchal
retraçant sa victoire à la star academy
jusqu'à sa disparition prématurée en
raison de la mucoviscidose à 23 ans
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire de ce jeune candidat touché
par la grâce continue de faire parler
sauf que voilà depuis quelques jours
l'admiration semble avoir laissé place à
un vent de suspicion autour du
traitement médiatique particulier auquel
auraient eu droit le jeune homme lors de
son passage dans l'émission star
académie je ressens un peu trop le côté
business autour
malheureusement de la maladie c'est
d'abord l'ancien professeur de chant du
château isabelle charles qui expliquait
en faisant son casting de départ la
production pouvait tout à fait choisir
quel serait son quatuor final vous
engagez grégory ensuite ceux qui vont
aller en face de lui un aveu à demi mot
que la victoire du jeune homme aurait
été orchestrée par la production
son de cloche similaire du côté
d'armande altaï star du programme
je l'avais dit qu'il avait la
mucoviscidose aussi ce qui je dois bien
les intéressait aussi pour mathieu
johann ancien candidat aux côtés de
grégory la production scénarisé la vie
au château est ainsi pouvait favoriser
tel ou tel candidat
scénarisée n'est pas truquée on est dans
une émission télé réalité la prod
scénarisé mais en fonction de ce qu'on
leur donnait de ce qu'on offrait comme
prestation des propos qui diffère
quelque peu de la version idéalisée de
l'histoire de grégory raconté dans le
téléfilm qui lui est consacré
[Musique]
elle a beaucoup qui ont été vite dans ce
récap web mondial jean pascal lacoste
qui a fait la première star academy
oui alors selon vous selon moi alors la
télé reste un divertissement
il n'y a pas de hasard c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui c'est très peu de direct
etc
moi personnellement et je connais un peu
armande que la production se soit appuyé
sur sa maladie
malheureusement ça ne me choque pas si
c'est rentrer en guinée compte moi je
pense que ça ça n'empêche pas le talent
qui l'avait etc mais je pense que ça
aide aussi c'est triste mais pour les
audiences pour les la question à
l'envers imaginant que grégory lemarchal
brillante et très mal
oui mais qui lui comme ces deux maladies
à votre avis qui leur était gagnante est
très bien il avait du talent qui soit
meilleur qu'aujourd'hui la télé elle se
sert aussi de ça alors je le répète à
tous ceux qui nous regardent je n'ai
rien contre l'association ni tf1
ça évitera que vous cassiez les couilles
de pâques ou y aller ou pas loi là et
dans les antilles est sa non du passage
au tour de moubarak mois et non mais je
pense que ces travaux ok mais ça me
choque pas que la production s'en
servent parce qu'aujourd'hui
voilà c'est des shows télé s'est
préparée et moi je pense qu'à une grosse
part de vérité là dessus et après si un
peu pénible 6 il y en a beaucoup qui
servent de ça pour reprendre un peu de
lumière sur ces photos j'ai
personnellement toujours trop facile du
jour que après faut en effet en panne à
opel
enfin grégory ouioui il avait cette
maladie
mais à côté de ça il avait un gros
talent sur un énorme talent et tout est
fait pour moi pertes et mes mots sinon
ben kay
je n'ai pas de bateau il était très bien
cette maladie
et maxime gainey a eu et oui mesdames
messieurs max maya n'y a eu un scoop
puisqu'il a reçu la porte de questions
alors c'est pas la preuve des chances et
la finaliste à wimbledon et à la
promotion de relations a mis au profit
d'ailleurs de l'association grégory
lemarchal
l'album est effectivement elle nous
disait très clairement qu'il est adéquat
on regarde regarde
ah oui j'ai arriver là dessus et sur
vers la finale j'ai juste voulu essayer
de faire au mieux et je commençais déjà
à reprendre plus de temps pour écrire
mes chansons et pour préparer la sortie
etc etc et j'ai vu que ça sent cependant
dire sans sans pression en fait on a
vécu une finale du cou où il n'y avait
aucune pression je savais je savais que
grégory allait gagner
je le savais donc si tu veux ça ne
pouvait être que du bonheur et du coup
les miens étaient réelles cette
révélation c'est jeu d'où révélations
alors c'est une pseudo révéler vos mots
moi je trouve ça un petit peu lamentable
à présent après vraiment incident après
son décès de casser un petit peu ce me
grégory lemarchal avait du talent il a
gagné parce qu'il avait du talent pas
parce qu'il avait un handicap vont
arrêter de croire à un moment donné que
le handicap ouvre des portes ou fait du
favoritisme
si tf1 a mis en lumière la mucovisidose
tant mieux parce qu'aujourd'hui la
mucoviscidose n'était pas connu et grâce
à peut-être à tf1 oui à grégory
lemarchal surtout à tf1 et à la star ac
eh bien ça a mis en lumière cette
maladie et ça a permis de créer toutes
ces associations
mais treize ans après de dire que tf1
que la production de star ac l'a fait
gagner parce qu'il avait la mucovisidose
je trouve ça de la part de isabelle
charles excusez moi mais lamentable
s'est dit alors le monde d'accord
cocteau comme ça tu es d'exemple cote
magalie vaé avancer dans ma démission je
peux vous dire que tf1
ils ont tout fait pour qu'ils n'y a pas
du tout je ne crois pas du tout
il a annoncé le vote des gens et puisque
dit lucie c'est pas du tout que ça
orchestré elle dit moi je savais pas ce
qu'il a toujours dit elle n'a jamais
caché a dit moi je savais qu'il était
meilleur qu'il était excellent que
c'était la voix d'un ange comme on
n'arrêtait pas de le dire
voilà fin de la discussion concernant ce
sujet